what's your name
I'm Siri pleased to meet you my nickname
is the Google Assistant the name's Bixby
I'm Alexa
I've talked and made jokes in the past
mostly along the lines of uh Google
assistant is clearly the best virtual
assistant and then Bixby Siri and Alexa
are various levels of far behind but
last time I did this type of test was
2017. so I figured we should revisit
this a little bit retest things and
figure out if Google Assistant still
actually is the best virtual assistant
on a smartphone right now also shout out
to clippy the original virtual assistant
whose ugly Christmas sweater for
Microsoft is actually what inspired this
one the MKBHD 8-bit drip which you can
get while supplies last they're very
limited but they're at shop that one can
phd.com link below but I decided to
start with the simple questions you know
the three things that you ask from an
assistant the most often I think are the
weather timers and facts so they all do
fine with the weather question probably
the number one query for me anyway and
then for the most part there were also
the same pretty quick with just asking
standard facts although for some reason
they did disagree on the height of one
person but then for timers for timers
for one weird reason Siri cannot do
multiple timers at the same time on the
iPhone if you have a timer running and
ask for a second timer it asks you every
time time if you want to replace the
first timer pretty basic stuff that I'm
not sure why Apple hasn't fixed yet
especially because you can set multiple
timers at the same time with Siri on a
homepod mini but anyway I don't want to
make you watch a whole bunch of back to
back to back questions and answers
because as I admit it was kind of boring
when I was doing all that testing but
I'm going to share some examples of what
I found with you and then some of the
highlights of the testing and the way it
answers these questions and you interact
with them so here we go so with all the
latest software updates on every
assistant all being asked the exact same
questions asked to do the exact same
tasks with the same phrasing and on the
same Wi-Fi connections most often the
fastest one to answer was Google
assistant or Siri but but Siri and Bixby
in my experience did have the most
instances of like hanging and pausing
and not really answering a question kind
of like acting like they had a poor
internet connection even though they
didn't not sure why they did that a
restart of the phone helped with the
Bixby one series kind of does it
randomly not sure why but that's a real
fact but then with straight up fact
questions there is no runaway winner
which I think is a good thing actually
so if you ask something that's easily
googleable or on Wikipedia something
like how tall is the Taj Mahal they can
all get it or if you ask what do whales
eat they all had some type of answer for
me that was basically the same Siri I
found relies the most heavily on
Wikipedia as a source for almost all of
its answers and then when it does have
to go outside of that it just kind of
throws up a web search link often with
Wikipedia at the top says look what I
Googled for you now Google assistant is
the most likely to give you a nice
visual and slightly more information
than you asked for Bixby is powered by
Google so I would say it's the most
likely to read what Google Assistant
reads word for word and then Alexa is
the most likely to throw in some extra
information about your latest Amazon
order or something random so facts they
can all do great then there is what I
call the device control category because
these are assistants that are on your
smartphones that are smart speakers as
well but on your phone you'd like to be
able to help you out with things while
you can't use your hands and for this
there was a runaway winner actually two
and that would be Google assistant and
Bixby so with the most basic basic stuff
though they're pretty much all fine they
can all change their screen brightness
for example except Alexa but they can
also all open the camera or pretty much
any app on your phone with a voice
command that's easy setting an alarm is
light work if you ask it actually to
open the app store they all open their
respective app stores and actually Bixby
opens the Samsung Galaxy store which is
kind of cheeky but when it starts to get
more complex Google and Bixby start to
walk away from the others so if I ask it
to take a selfie Siri and Alexa will
just open the camera but Bixby and
Google actually open the camera switch
to the selfie camera and start a
self-timer and actually take a selfie if
I want to say play squid game on Netflix
both Google and Bix B will actually open
the Netflix app find the first episode
of squid game I haven't seen yet or
wherever I left off and start playing it
Siri just opens the app and Alexa is
lost if I say uh start a voice recording
or a voice memo for Siri again Google
and Bixby open the voice recording app
and actually start that recording Siri
again just opens the app and again Alexa
is lost these voice commands when they
work are legitimately faster than I
would have been able to do it by hand
for the most part and there's a bunch of
other device specific stuff that
Samsung's programmed into Bixby where it
can reach into Apps and perform specific
commands within them so if there are
apps you use a lot this can potentially
save you a lot of time Bixby was also
great at this last time I did it and
also Alexa is unsurprisingly the worst
at device control because they aren't
making their own phone these aren't
Amazon phones so the vertical
integration is great with Siri and
Google assistant and Bixby not with
Alexa not a shocker there what might be
a little bit of a surprise though
is conversationalism who is the coach of
the Phoenix Suns
how tall is he
did he play in the NBA
[Music]
what team did he play for
so you can see Siri tapped out after
about four questions in a row about the
same thing but Google assistant is
incredible at this it's really really
good at remembering the context and the
subject of a natural conversation and
carrying that on through a bunch of
questions in a row where is the Taj
Mahal
okay how tall is it
how many meters is that
what is it made of
say again Google remembers what we're
talking about when is the weekend's
birthday
what's their latest album
what's his real name
so basically if you're asking a bunch of
questions in a row or if you have one
subject that you want to basically
research through the voice assistant or
get a bunch of answers on your best bet
is definitely Google assistant and then
one more interesting thing from the
queries that I asked just as far as
getting pictures when you ask for
pictures of something like dogs for
example they can all search the web
except Bixby didn't and Alexa which is
looking for an Amazon photos app for
some reason but when you say show me my
pictures of dogs Google actually opens
and searches in my own photos album for
my own pictures of dogs so I did a bunch
of other testing like this with a bunch
of other different questions different
styles of questions follow-up questions
and things like that and I've come to a
pretty solid conclusion so if you're
wondering which one is the best Marquez
you did all these tests which one came
out as number one
only one thing became exceptionally
clear through all this testing which is
that Alexa is clearly the worst it is
clearly far behind the others as a smart
assistant on a phone even if I mean
unless maybe you're already deep in the
Amazon Alexa ecosystem with everything
working perfectly in your smart home
matter of fact this really is an
ecosystem question almost as much as it
is a skills question for the assistants
because if you are super all in on one
of these smart home ecosystems that
actually could answer the question for
you of course if you're all in with
homekit then Siri and an iPhone is your
only option to view your cameras and see
your doorbell ringing and turn on your
lights and all that stuff but if you are
doing the same with Google home and
Google Assistant then you're there now
the next gen matter standard may change
all of this it may actually make this
section irrelevant maybe leave a thumbs
up on this video or comment if you're
interested in a video about that
specifically but for now with these
different silos of Home ecosystems
that's pretty important but I'll still
say from my most common experiences and
queries and the things that are most
useful across every single Phone iPhones
or Android phones the most useful
assistant is still Google assistant and
that's multiplied if you also happen to
have a pixel phone because then you also
get you know call screening and hold for
me and all those extra pixel features
but in general Google assistant is most
likely to be fast it's most likely to
give a good well-sourced answer it's
most likely to be conversational and
remember context longer and has a bunch
of third-party plugs tons of app support
and I also happen to have built my smart
home in the Google home world so it's
great now for the second best I'm very
tempted to say Bixby of course though
this is only relevant if you have a
Samsung phone and also it is basically
saying all the same first query
responses that Google Assistant was
minus the ability to talk to a Smart
speaker since you know Samsung would
probably like us to forget about that
but I am going to have to put Siri in
second place here it's fine it's okay
it's all right it's fine it's not great
uh but it is the most well plugged into
Apple's ecosystem so of course if you're
doing homekit stuff it's going to work
well there it does support a smart
speaker which can do multiple timers if
you're not doing stuff all the time on
your phone and it does support routines
which is like stacking a bunch of
different commands into one action if
you're willing to dig through the very
convoluted series shortcuts interface so
that puts Bixby in third place and Alexa
is just bad it's just bad on a phone
like there there was a phone a couple
years ago an HTC phone where it was
built in so there's a Google assistant
and Alexa side by side on the same phone
and it worked kind of well back then but
that was years ago and Alexa is just
dead last on a phone right now and
Amazon knows it Amazon is falling behind
with a like and if you're just starting
to use Assistance or put together a
smart home or this type of stuff I would
say avoid things that are Alexa
exclusive right now but until then let
me know if you agree that Google
Assistant still seems pretty far out in
front or maybe there are some specific
features that you find the most useful
in a virtual assistant let me know in
the comments either way Channel sponsor
dbrand also would like you to know that
they are relaunching the Damascus skin
they're bringing it back due to popular
demand it's got all this like crazy
reflective holographic chaos you can
kind of skin whatever device you want to
so you can make it work and you get a
free triple black skin with your order
which is sick I'll link it below thanks
for watching and I'll catch you guys in
the next one peace
[Music]